Here are two people. They're both standing,
but they're standing in two completely different
ways. Which person would it be easier to push
over? If you wanted to push this person [left]
over, where would you apply a force? What
about this [right] person? The answers to
all these questions can be explained using
the concept of torque.
This video is part of the Representations
video series. Information can be represented
in words, through mathematical symbols, graphically,
or in 3-D models. Representations are used
to develop a deeper and more flexible understanding
of objects, systems, and processes.
Hi. I'm Sanjay Sarma. Professor of mechanical
engineering at MIT, In this video, we'll be
talking torque and balance.
In order to understand these core concepts,
you'll need a working knowledge of vectors
and their uses. Specifically, you must be
familiar with force, displacement, and torque.
We will also assume that you know how to compute
a cross product, and how to use the Right-Hand
Rule, and that you have done problems involving
the center of mass of an object.
Our objective is to improve your ability to
draw torque diagrams, and give you some practice
with setting them up. By the end you should
also understand what is needed for human beings
to balance.
We'll start with an activity. Everyone stand
up and spread out across the room. You'll
need a partner for this activity.
When I say "go," your goal is to carefully
push your partner over. Use the smallest amount
of force you can. You will switch partners
halfway through, so be gentle.
When you push, consider where you should push,
and in what direction. Try many different
approaches.
Here are some questions that may help you
think about this in a scientific manner. When
it comes to your push, where will you push?
What direction will you push? How hard will
you push? Consider your partner as well: how
is your partner standing? What is the floor
like under your partner's feet? Can your partner
balance well?
Are you ready? Go!
Switch partners!
Your teacher will now lead you in a short
discussion about this activity. Pause the
video here.
Let's continue our investigation of torque
and balance in the human body. Take a look
at this next video clip, in which MIT researchers
Colin Fredericks and Jennifer French demonstrate
the effectiveness of properly applied torque.
[Colin speaking] This is called "Sai son"
stance. This is a basic stance in martial
arts. Known for it's stability along a particular
direction.
This is my colleague, mathematician Jennifer
French.
Jen knows the stance is strong along certain
directions–such as the one she is pulling
in now.
[laughing] Oops.
It can also withstand a great deal of force
in the opposite direction.
I'm not going to be knocked over if she is
pushing or pulling along that particular line.
However, Jen knows the stance's weak point.
If she pushes along a different line, it'll
knock me right down to the ground.
This isn't just martial arts. This is science.
Torque controls my ability to balance and
we're going to show you how today.
[Sanjay speaking] To analyze the situation,
let's look at what physical properties are
important here.
What forces do you think are involved? Pause
the video to discuss.
Next, draw a simple diagram that you can use
to find the net torque on this man. Pause
the video while you do this.
The simplest way to represent this man is
with a rectangle. You should remove any other
details, and draw our forces so that we can
tell exactly where they are applied to his body.
Finally, if you were to draw a diagram showing
someone resisting a push, how would you do
it? Which of these three is most appropriate?
Pause the video to discuss.
You may be wondering why we can use a two-dimensional
diagram to discuss a three-dimensional situation.
The reason is that all of our forces are applied
in the same plane, simplifying the problem.
While our torque vectors point in and out
of the screen on this diagram, we can represent
that fairly easily. In a more complex situation,
we may need to draw something more fully three-dimensional,
as our torques might point in other directions.
This next video clip will walk you through
a partial analysis of this situation. You
will need a way to take notes and draw diagrams
while you watch.
[Jen speaking] I couldn't push Colin over
by applying force in the stable direction.
Yet when I applies the same force in a different
direction, I could push him over.
How did I know this?
Torque.
Here you see two 2-dimensional views representing
Colin.
The width of the base represents the distance
between his feet.
The wide square is the view of Colin from
the side and stable states.
The narrow rectangle is the view of Colin
from straight on.
Lets draw in the forces acting on Colin as
I push him in the stable directions.
Start by drawing the center of mass.
Which we assume is at the center of the square.
The force of gravity pulls straight down with
magnitude three halfs.
There is also the force of my push of length
one. Which we place in the location where
the force is applied.
This push shifts Colin's weight entirely to
his back foot. So the normal force is applied
there with a magnitude equal and opposite
that of force p.
The force of friction is also at this foot.
Equal and opposite the magnitude and direction
of the push force.
Recall that torque is r cross F.
That is, torque occurs when a force is applied
some displacement distance from a reference
point.
We can choose any reference point we like,
and the net torque we compute will be the
same.
For this problem I will choose the reference
point to be the pivot point.
Why don't you try this problem but choose
the center of mass as the reference point.
Lets get back to the problem.
The push force and the gravitation force are
applied some distance from the pivot point
at the foot.
So they will create torque.
However, the friction force and normal force
are applied at the pivot point.
So R is zero and we can ignore that when we
compute the net torque.
Lets compute the torque due to the push force.
The vector r is the displacement from the
pivot point to where the force is applied.
We decompose this vector into its x and y
components.
We use a coordinate system with origin at
the pivot point to determine the r vector
to be 4i + 3j.
The magnitude of the push force is negative
one i.
The magnitude of torque can be found as the
magnitude of r times the magnitude of F times
sin theta.
Where theta is the angle between the two vectors.
Thus the magnitude is the area of the parallelogram
formed by r and F.
Since the area of this parallelogram is also
the area of the rectangle formed by F and
r sin theta or the component of r that is
perpendicular to F.
We can see this magnitude visually as the
area of this rectangle.
We will show the magnitudes in this way because
it is very easy to see the relative magnitudes
of the various torques.
So...
For the push force the area is 3, which mean
the magnitude of the torque is 3.
The direction of the torque vector is along
the axis of rotation caused by this force.
We find the direction using the right hand
wall.
Point our fingers along r and curl along F.
In this case we find the direction to be out
of the board or positive k.
So this tells us that the torque due to the
push force is equal to 3k.
We can also find the torque vector by taking
the determinate of the following three by
three matrix.
The first row is i, j, and k.
The second row are the x, y, and z components
of the r vector.
And the third row are the x, y , and z components
of the force vector.
Because r and F lie in the same plane, the
z components are zero.
In our example, the force is pointing in the
negative i direction and r we found to be
4 i plus 3 j.
Computing it this way, we also find that the
torque is 3k.
Now let's find the torque due to gravity.
The vector r is found by connecting the pivot
point to the center of mass.
We leave to you to pause the video and to
determine the components of r using this coordinate
system.
We find the magnitude of the torque by taking
the component of r that is perpendicular to
F pointing in the x direction, and the magnitude
is the area of the rectangle between these
two vectors.
Again, we find the direction using the right
hand rule.
We find the torque to be pointing into the
board at the pivot point.
Since the x component of the r vector is 2,
and the force due to gravity is 3 halves,
pointing in the negative j direction.
The magnitude of the torque due to gravity
is 3 and it points in the negative k direction.
So the torque is negative 3 k at the pivot
point.
Adding the push torque and the gravity torque
together we find that we get zero.
This means that there is no rotation about
the pivot point.
Now let's look in the unstable direction.
We have all the same forces as before- force
of gravity at the center of mass, the push
force, a normal force at the back foot, as
well as a friction force.
The magnitudes of these forces are all the
same as in the other diagram.
Let's compute the torque due to the push force.
The vector r connects the pivot point to the
place where the force is applied.
Using our coordinate axes with the origin
placed at the pivot point, we find this vector
to be i plus 3 j.
We find the magnitude of the torque vector
is the area of the rectangle formed by force
vector and the component of r, perpendicular
to F.
Thus the area is one times three, or three.
In order to find the direction, we use the
right hand rule. Point our fingers along r,
curl in the direction of F, and our thumb
points out of the board, so the direction
of our torque is k.
Since the magnitude is 3, that tells us that
torque due to the push is 3 k at the pivot
point.
Finally, let's find the torque due to gravity.
Start by drawing the r vector from the pivot
point to the center of mass.
Now let's decompose this vector into it's
x and y components.
We leave this as an exercise to you, using
the coordinate system shown here.
The magnitude of the torque due to gravity
at the pivot point is found by the area of
the rectangle form by the force vector and
the x component of the r vector.
The direction is found using the right hand
rule, pointing our fingers along r and curling
around F.
In other words, into the board or negative
k.
So the torque due to gravity is one-half times
three-halves or three-fourths pointing in
the negative k direction.
The net torque about the pivot point is the
sum of these two.
In other words, the torque push plus the torque
due to gravity is the net torque around the
pivot point, which is two and a quarter the
positive k direction.
That means there is a total net rotation about
the pivot point. Causing Colin to fall over.
We leave it as an exercise for you to use
the determinate in order to compute the torque
vectors.
If you computed the net torque using the center
of mass as the reference point, you should
notice that the net torques that you found
are equal to the net torques that we computed
here.
[Sanjay speaking] Now that you've seen torque
and balancing in detail, let's consider a
more complex problem. This one is a bit tricky.
I'll show you how it works.
I'm going to take a chair and place it next
to the wall.
I'll put my toes up to the wall, and step
back, toe-to-heel, twice.
I step sideways until I'm over the chair.
Then I bend forward until my head touches
the wall, pick up the chair, and stand up...
er... or not.
This is something that most women can do,
but men cannot.
Maybe you think it's a trick? Here's a video
of some of your professors trying to lift
[Jen speaking]Okay, walk up to the wall.
Yes.
Then heel toe heel toe.
That's it. One more time.
And now translate over but don't come in or
out.
Okay.
Now bend over to the the wall. Bend over.
Put your head on the wall.
Mmm-hmm.
Pick the chair up.
Now stand up.
Hah!
[laughing]
That's fair enough. Don't hurt yourself.
No, no. There was actually no way. [laughing]
Toes against the wall.
One.
Two. Okay, translate over. You might be able
to do it because his feet are proportionately
small.
Okay, down.
Pick it up.
[giggle]
Pick up the chair first. Please pick up of
the chair please.
Now stand up.
[laughing]
Okay. One over.
Bend over.
Ohhh, okay.
Alright.
Okay, then do it one more time with the other
foot.
Okay, now can translate over a little bit?
Just move over but don't go in or out.
Well, no. You want a line there.
Actually... be in a little.
There you go.
No no no- you're fine! Just even up your feet.
Okay.
Bend over. Put your hands on the wall, just
so you don't hit your head.
Okay...
now pick up the chair.
Now stand up.
No no. Don't do it again. You have to pick
up the chair. Clean pick up.
Now stand up.
Alright! [clapping]
[Sanjay speaking] Now it's your turn to try.
Get together with your partner again and bring
a chair over to the wall.
Why don't you pause the video and give it
a try?
Now that you've attempted the chair lift,
let's return to our seats and discuss what
happened.
If you wanted to figure out why this happens,
what information would you need?
What assumptions would you have to make?
Discuss the matter with your partner. Try
to draw a diagram of the situation.
Pause the video here while you work this out.
Many of you should be wondering about the
center of mass for this situation.
This diagram shows typical locations for the
center of mass in men (on the left) and women
(on the right).
Not only are men typically taller, but their
center of mass is usually higher in their
bodies.
This is not always true, but it is fairly
typical.
Using this information, work with your partner
to try to explain what is happening.
Why can women lift the chair when men cannot?
You do not need to obtain a numerical solution.
Instead, use reasoned arguments, diagrams,
and well-supported assumptions to prove your
answer.
Only use calculations if you cannot support
your answer in any other way.
Pause the video and give it a try.
Are you ready to see the solution?
Let's take a look.
For this section we will measure torques around
the center of mass.
This will simplify our work so that we don't
have to worry about the person's mass and
the pull of gravity.
This diagram shows the man lifting the chair.
You can see that the center of mass is outside
his body, and has been moved farther forward
and down by the chair.
This diagram shows the same for the woman.
Her center of mass is also outside her body,
but is much closer to her legs.
If we draw a line for the man to indicate
where his toes are, you see that the center
of mass is beyond the edge of his foot!
No matter how hard he tries, he simply cannot
apply force in the right place to lift that
chair.
On our diagram, we can see that the torque
will always point in the direction out of
the screen.
It will rotate the man counterclockwise, pushing
his head harder into the wall.
The harder he pushes, the worse it will be.
The woman, however, has her center of mass
above her feet.
She can stand up because her feet are able
to apply force in the proper location and
direction.
If we draw a torque diagram, we can see that
the direction of torque applied by her feet
will be into the screen.
By applying more force, she can rotate her
upper body clockwise and stand up, whereas
the man cannot.
Today we hope that you have improved your
ability to draw torque diagrams, and to analyze
torque problems that occur in the real world.
Torque is an important quantity that comes
into play in countless situations around us,
from machinery to buildings to the simple
act of walking. I hope you enjoyed this look
at one of its fascinating applications.